Hmm.
I identify as a liberal because I was raised by a super strong feminist mother
and I believe in equal rights for all human beings.
I hate definition,
I'm a conservative because I voted for Donald Trump.
The liberal policies are more humanistic,
inclusive and less restrictive.
I believe that my conservative values align most with my morals.
Conservative.
Gotcha.
Okay.
I am nervous.
Think these topics are,
I think they're really a sensitive to a lot of people and a lot of people feel
very strongly and know a lot of feelings get hurt and you see that in society
and stuff like that,
so that's fine.
I'm going to risk because like yeah,
we were forming relationships with like talking,
getting to know each other outside.
Just like now,
is it all gonna Change?
Like
let's hope not.
Yeah.
I personally think that it's,
you're in my pants,
your civic duty to vote.
Yup.
And I don't see why you can complain if you didn't take the initiative to go out
and let your voice be heard.
And that's what it is.
That people should be going out and making their voices heard and that should be
just general,
like what we do because that's what we are supposed to do as opposed to,
oh,
I somebody else will take care of it.
Oh,
it's not my problem all,
I don't know
is it
most of the people I know that didn't vote kind of non voted their conscience
and yet I think that everyone should still have a say in right to be
participating in,
I wouldn't want to just silence somewhere
then they should be participating.
That's that.
That's the issue is they aren't participants,
but they're not seeing any value in the local elections at all.
Yeah.
There's a lot of things other than
your friends.
Do they go,
look,
I saw no value in any local election at all.
Zero.
Nothing carry about any local action.
Guys do realize a lot of the people being affected by Trump are people who can't
even vote,
so they're complaining.
I'm like,
go ahead,
complain.
You've been here since you were six,
five months old.
You still can't vote or you ever to tell those people and they don't have it,
right.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I think those people have a right to complain.
However,
my beliefs and my thoughts are pointing towards people who are,
have the ability to have all of the rights and the ability to register,
to vote or to vote.
No.
Yes.
I agree with what you guys have.
Your premise that if you can vote people who cannot vote,
they don't have that.
Right.
That's true.
So that's why I disagree.
Uh,
I'm not going to lie.
I didn't vote.
So all y'all in the comments,
you guys can put it in there now.
Uh Huh.
I think Donald Trump is doing the best job and became,
I think
my personal favorite.
I'm not,
I don't agree with a lot of the ways he conducted himself in his presidential
campaign,
but I think if we look at him versus look at him from before he was elected
president and he's a very,
very different person.
Um,
we're not in world war three,
so
we used to have the same freedoms.
We can still talk about it and like it's still not liking.
You can still all these things and I think that you could be doing the worst job
in is doing right now.
It could be much worse.
I think he's doing the worst job.
Like when did it be okay for him to be the least common denominator?
When was it okay for our president?
Are the leader of this country to be oh well he's was not as bad as he could.
Yeah.
Um,
I'll be honest,
I didn't vote for Donald Trump,
but on January 20th I said,
you know,
I hope it does the best job just like an Obama did.
I said,
I hope he does because that's,
I have to put my faith in the office of the president regardless of bright,
bold it,
whoever that is,
they deserve my respect.
The only reason I voted for him or the primary reason was because Ben Carson
came out and supported him.
That's how a conservative would behave,
is not going to be swearing.
It's not going to go through a divorce and he's not going to be on the news
saying stupid things that is more conservative person would look like to me
like that.
Yes.
I think the people of the opposite party
do not know that.
I just think that people don't,
you get different experiences so you're going to learn differently.
You're going to see things through different,
through different lenses
and today feel like there's missed information on a lot of the conservative
side.
You guys have info wars,
you guys have things that are blatantly saying sandy hook was fake,
that the hurricanes are to populate.
Um,
climate change like there that we have an agenda as in like there is another
reason for us besides saving humanity to try and do something about what we're
causing.
It just comes back to they don't,
what do you believe to be true and why?
I think sometimes,
um,
when I've had interactions with people that disagree,
there's so much emotion attached to it and it's hard.
Hey everyone,
I'm glad you don't think we're misinformed by appreciate.
Well,
I think if there's drinks,
so like I was listening in,
Jen,
when you were talking about the kind of things that you feel like conservatives
disagree upon her or think about,
I think you were discussing a radical sect of conservatism.
What is promoted is not,
but that is not what most people are relating to.
If you,
if you went out in the,
you're associating yourself with those values so you
there you have the white supremacists were like,
we are a Christian.
You have the,
unfortunately that's not what most people use.
The same thing with,
I mean most of those people are great.
My biggest problem right now is that each party is painted with one broad stroke
of everybody falls under 10 things challenge.
At least the reason I didn't come in cause I don't think the other side is
missing,
but I think we're informed differently.
Exactly.
It's interesting.
Social media allows you to interact with people.
They're very,
very different.
You guys friend me on Facebook,
you'll see I'm friends with more people that disagree with me than agree with
me.
I don't care what you believe.
I'm really,
really,
really interested in like eight wise,
like I believe this,
well why I believe this?
Why,
why,
why?
And,
and that's,
that's something that only happens when you develop a friendship or a lot of
interaction.
Yeah.
To be in the mirror
and to think about that a little bit.
It's like,
you know,
you might love your child but not be happy with how they're acting right now.
And I see things that upset me and embarrass me about how we are and yet our
possibilities,
the way we respond to people all over the world are coming to our values.
I'm still proud,
but not maybe as proud as I used to be.
There's a lot of freedom in what you can say.
And I think there's a lot of power in that because I know a lot of people in
other countries,
um,
if they say anything about the government,
like they'll disappear the next day.
And I get to,
um,
not only voice my opinion,
but also live it,
being able to do whatever you want to do,
make who you want out of yourself.
That's really awesome.
I was surprise my son.
I thought the
idea of how this was going to be,
that there would be more polar,
it rise.
The more agreement and I see it more centrist.
Most people do agree.
Why?
I don't think Trump borders represent all conservatives are all republicans.
No.
Then there a big population though.
I think tonight,
today I was pleasantly surprised everyone because I think that centrist
Messenger may be that I agree with you,
but I also hold my beliefs and I respect that.
I think that's something that we need the,
it should be happening more and more because I think there's so many
conversations where I keep up with this crazy person talked to,
they think there's no,
it's we disagree,
but that's okay.
I didn't expect to to be super argumentative where you know,
we have to be on civil about things because you know people,
people are going to think differently and if you can think for yourself and
think about the position you're in,
it's very hard to argue with somebody and it's very,
very,
very hard to really dislike somebody just because they believe something else.
But I was happy to hear,
uh,
all of us,
it kind of be on the same level really as far as social issues.
Like,
I mean,
as far as being people as opposed to like,
this is my side and this is what I'm right.
You know,
and that's much better.
I was pleasantly surprised.
It's okay,
I'm going to Facebook or anything in it,
right.
Because you see the name,
what's it go wrong?